THE. WILL COME TO ORDER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
ALAN. ALVARADO GIL ARCHULETA,
ASHBY, ATKINS, BECKER,
BLAKESPEAR, BRADFORD CABALLERO,
CORTEZ DALI. GOD DURAO EGM
GLASER, GONZALEZ GROVE, TAO
JONES, LAIRD LIMÓN MAGUIRE
MENJIVAR MIN. NEW MEN. WEN NILO,
OCHO, PADILLA, PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALL
WORK. CUEVAS STERN, HUMBERG
WAHAB WIENER WILK. QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL. PLEASE
RISE. WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN, AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
FLAGS, MR GORMAN. WE GATHER IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. WE BEGIN OUR
PRAYER WITH A QUOTE FROM
LANGSTON HUGHES. LIKE A WELCOME
SUMMER RAIN. HUMOR MAY SUDDENLY
CLEANSE AND COOL THE EARTH, THE
AIR AND YOU GRACIOUS GOD. WHO IS
NOT OFTEN CALLED HUMOROUS. AS WE
MOVE THROUGH OUR DAYS. HELP US
TO REMEMBER THE DIFFICULTIES WE
CREATE FOR OURSELVES BY TRYING
TO SHAPE THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AROUND US. AND BY HOLDING ON TO
THE ILLUSIONS OF CONTROL. LET US
NOT WHETHER IN THE TRIPLE DIGIT
HEAT OF SELF IMPORTANCE. SELF
WILL AND SELF CRITIQUE. HELP US
TO ALLOW HUMOR TO REFRESH OUR
PERSPECTIVES. TO SEE THE
HUMANNESS OF OUR LIVES AS A
BLESSING RATHER THAN A BURDEN.
KNOW OURSELVES IN A NEW WAY. AND
TO LOVE OURSELVES WITH A NEW
KINDNESS. AS WE RESPOND TENDERLY
TO THE PRESSURES WE PLACE ON
OURSELVES. MAY WE RELEASE THE
UNFAIRLY HIGH EXPECTATIONS WE
PLACE ON OTHERS. AND REJOICE IN
THE JOY OF OUR SHARED BEAUTIFUL
AND LIMITED PERSONHOOD WITHIN
THE HUMAN FAMILY. WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME. AMEN. THANK YOU,
SISTER GORMAN. FOR YOUR
INSIGHTFUL WORDS, PLEASE JOIN ME
MEMBERS AND GUESTS WITH A PLEDGE
TO OUR FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO DEVIATE
FROM OUR NORMAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS TODAY AND WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH AN ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. MEMBERS. WE'RE
GONNA START WITH ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER
16. YOUR MICROPHONE UP FROM
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION TODAY
REGARDING A B 16 6 10 THAT WE
MOVE A B 610 TO THE INACTIVE
FILE MEMBERS. I SUPPORTED THIS
BILL AS RECENTLY AS MONDAY IN
APPROPRIATIONS. IF YOU'VE MADE A
MOTION I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
MOTION. THANK YOU. OK AND I WANT
TO JUST SAY THAT, UH TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THIS IS A DEBATE
ON THE MERITS OF YOUR MOTION TO
CORRECT THE ITEM TO BE ENACTED
OR FILED NOT ON THE BILL ITSELF.
CORRECT I'M GOING TO SPEAK TO
THE MOTION. ABSOLUTELY PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF
US TO RECOGNIZE THAT A
BLISTERING MEDIA REPORT
PUBLISHED YESTERDAY INDICATES
THE EXEMPTIONS TO THE ORIGINAL
MANDATE ON THE MINIMUM WAGE HIKE
ARE TIED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS MEDIA
OUTLETS JUST AS RECENTLY AS
YESTERDAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
NATIONAL MEDIA ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS SPECIFIC BILL
AND CALLING IT PAY TO PLAY. PUT
SIMPLY, CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
SHOULD NOT BUY CARVE OUTS IN
LEGISLATION AND THIS BILL OR ANY
BILL THAT'S CRONY CAPITALISM.
IT'S CORRUPT AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE. I DIDN'T SUPPORT
THE ORIGINAL BILL AB 1228 THAT
CREATED THIS MINIMUM WAGE HIKE
AND I ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT MORE
EXEMPTIONS TO THAT BILL, AND WE
NEED MORE EXEMPTIONS BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT ANY BUSINESS
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO GOVERNMENT
MANDATES THAT INTERFERE WITH THE
FREE MARKET, ESPECIALLY COSTLY
ONES THAT PUT THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS. HOWEVER I THINK THE
SENATE WOULD BE REMISS BY
RUSHING TO PASS THIS BILL TODAY,
THE MAJOR PROVIDING EVEN MORE
EXEMPTIONS TO A LAW NOW
REPORTEDLY TIED TO PAYING
CONTRIBUTIONS. WE NEED TO SEND A
MESSAGE THAT THIS SENATE THAT
THIS HOUSE THESE MEMBERS THAT
THIS BIPARTISAN, UH, GROUP OF
LEGISLATORS THAT ARE TRYING TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA BETTER WILL NOT
CONDONE PAY TO PLAY ACTIONS OR
PERCEPTIONS PERIOD AT THIS
POINT. THE CLEANEST PATH FORWARD
IS TO SCRAP A B, 1228 AND 610
ENTIRELY AND START FROM SCRATCH.
AT THE VERY LEAST, WE SHOULD
HOLD ON MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD
UNTIL THERE CAN BE A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
ALLEGATIONS AT HAND. I
APPRECIATE THAT. WE WOULD, UH,
MOVE THIS BILL TO ENACT THE
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL TO THE
ENACT FILE. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE MAJORITY LEADER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NÓ VOTE ON
THIS MOTION, ALL RIGHT, ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS MOTION ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION? AND THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN OF G. NÓ ARCHULETA. NÓ
ASHBY, NÓ ATKINS. BECKER. NÓ
BLAKESPEAR. NÓ BRADFORD. NÓ
CABALLERO. NÓ CORTEZ. NÓ DALLY.
AYE, TODD. NÓ DUO. NÓ EDMUND. NÓ
BLAZER. OH, NÓ GONZALEZ. NÓ
GROVE. NÓ JONES. AYE, LAIRD. NÓ
LIMÓN. NÓ MAGUIRE. NÓ MANJAR. NÓ
MEN. NÓ NEWMAN. NÓ WHEN NEO AYE,
Ó. AYE, BARIA. NÓ PORTANTINO.
NÓ ROTH. NÓ RUBIO. NÓ SEYARTO.
AYE, SKINNER. NÓ SUAO CUEVAS. NÓ
STERN. NÓ UMBERG. NÓ W. NÓ
WEENER. NÓ WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN NÓ
ATKINS. GROVE. HØI WHEN HØI. ON
A VOTE OF EIGHT IN FAVOR 31
AGAINST THE MOTION TO MOVE THIS
ITEM TO THE INACTIVE FILE FAILS.
WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE TO THE TO
FILE ITEM. 16 THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 610. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
. ASSEMBLY BILL 610 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDING IN A RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR OF LEMON,
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I
RISE TO PRESENT A B 610 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
WHEN A B 1228 CAME BEFORE US
LAST YEAR, WE KNEW THAT
LEGISLATION WOULD BENEFIT
WORKERS AND RAISE WAGES. BUT WE
ALSO KNEW THAT THE BILL NEEDED
FURTHER CLEANUP. I COMMITTED TO
YOU THEN THAT WE WOULD ADDRESS
THOSE AREAS OF CONFLICT OF
CONFLICT WHILE STAYING TRUE TO
THE INTENT OF THE BILL. A B 610
ADDRESSES THE OVERLAP IN A B
1228 AS WELL AS WORKPLACES WHERE
A B 12,228 MAY HAVE AN
ESTABLISHED CEILING RATHER THAN
A FLOOR. THE BILL IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOALS SET OUT IN A B
1228, WHERE WORKERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD ENGAGED.
AND WHETHER AND WHETHER AND
THROUGH THE FAST FOOD COUNCIL
ORGANIZATIONS, EFFORTS,
REPRESENTATION OR CIVIL IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT THROUGH WAGE AND
BENEFIT ORDINANCES. DISCUSSIONS.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE AREAS OF
CONCERNS THAT WE ALL SHARED LAST
YEAR WHILE STILL CARRYING THE
PURPOSE OF A B 1228 FORD. FOR
THOSE REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. LIONE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, SENATOR DOLLY THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS. I RISE
TODAY TO JUST, UH I'M GONNA
ACTUALLY VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL.
AND THE REASON IS THAT THIS BILL
IS, UH, A CARVE OUT. FOR PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO PAY TO PLAY. YOU
KNOW, THE GOVERNOR JUST STATED
TODAY THAT IT'S THE WAY SAUSAGE
IS MADE. WELL, THERE'S A LOT OF
PORK IN SAUSAGE, IF YOU KNOW AND
A LOT OF HIS FRIENDS ARE GETTING
SOME PORK OUT OF THIS. SAME
THING HAPPENED LAST YEAR AND THE
YEAR BEFORE, WHEN WE HAD UH, THE
KAISER PERMANENTE DEAL THAT WAS
DONE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND $30
MILLION WAS BEHEST. IT I GUESS
IF YOU'RE IN THE BREAD MAKING
BUSINESS, THERE'S A LOT OF DOUGH
TO GO AROUND. BUT THIS IS, UM
JUST NOT RIGHT AT THE END OF THE
DAY. WE NEED TO PASS GOOD LAWS,
AND WE NEED TO NOT CARVE OUT,
UH, PEOPLE WHO ARE CAMPAIGN
DONORS. AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DOLLY AGAIN MEMBERS ON
THE MERITS OF THE BILL WHEN I
RECOGNIZE SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
UH, I. I ACTUALLY VOTED FOR THIS
IN THE LABOR COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
DID NOT SUPPORT THE REGIONAL
BILL AND ALL WE CAN DO TO MAKE
IT BETTER. I'M NORMALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF BUT IN LIGHT OF,
UH, THE RECENT THE RECENT
ALLEGATIONS AND THE LONG HISTORY
OF SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
SENATOR THE CENTER FOR BEAVER
LAID OUT, I'M I'M JUST GONNA LAY
OFF THIS BILL TODAY. I. I THINK
THAT WE REALLY DO NEED TO TAKE A
SERIOUS LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I IF WHAT IS ALLEGED IS
TRUE, IT IS NOT SO WITH THAT I'M
GONNA LAY OFF TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WILK, SENATOR SENATOR
SARTA. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO SPEAK
ABOUT THIS BILL. AND AT FIRST I
WAS LEANING TOWARDS VOTING FOR
IT. THEN I WAS THINKING ABOUT
JUST LAYING OFF OF IT. BUT NOW
I'M THINKING ABOUT VOTING NÓ ON
IT. I'LL TELL YOU WHY. BECAUSE
AFTER DOING A LITTLE
INVESTIGATION JUST THIS MORNING.
I FIND OUT THAT WHAT THIS BILL
REALLY REPRESENTS. IS PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO HELP OUT
AND CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. THEY'RE GOING
TO GET AN EXEMPTION. WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AIRPORTS, AIRPORTS
ARE ALREADY UNIONIZED. SO
THERE'S THE FLOOR FOR THEIR
MINIMUM WAGE ESSENTIALLY IS
HIGHER THAN THE REST OF, UH, OF
WHAT CALIFORNIA IS. AND HAVE
THAT FROM A SOURCE WHO WORKS AT
THE AIRPORT. UNDERSTANDS THESE
THE INDIVIDUAL STOREFRONTS. ARE
OWNED BY A LOT ARE OWNED BY
FOREIGN COMPANIES. AND THEN
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO. THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO LEASE THESE
INDIVIDUAL SPACES TO
UNDERPRIVILEGED. PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY, BUT THAT'S NOT HOW IT
WORKS. BUT HOW IT WORKS IS THEY
WIND UP LEASING IT TO WHOEVER IT
IS THAT THEY'RE CONNECTED TO. SO
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE MALLS.
BUT THE LIST OF EXEMPTIONS IN
THERE POINT TO ONE THING, THEY
HAVE THE MONEY. THEY HAVE THE
MONEY TO CARVE OUT AN EXEMPTION
FOR THEMSELVES. BUT LET ME TALK
ABOUT SOMEBODY WHO DOES NOT HAVE
AN EXEMPTION. AND IF AND IF THIS
HAD LANGUAGE IN IT TO PROTECT
PEOPLE LIKE THAT, I VOTE FOR IT.
BUT IT DOESN'T I HAVE A YOUNG
MAN. LIVES IN MURRIETA WENT TO
OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS. ARETAS CAME
TO TOWN. AND HE SIGNED UP TO
WORK THERE. HE BECAME THE
MANAGER OF THE READERS. MY
DAUGHTER GOT HER FIRST JOB THERE
. AS SOON AS SHE TURNED 16, SHE
RAN AROUND TOWN, PUTTING IN
APPLICATIONS EVERYWHERE. THE
ONLY PLACE YOU CAN GET A JOB WAS
AT RITA'S, BECAUSE GUESS WHAT?
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO. THEY HIRE
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. THEY HIRE OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AT MINIMUM WAGE.
SHE WASN'T THERE SO SHE COULD
MAKE MONEY TO BUY A HOUSE. SHE
WAS THERE TO MAKE MONEY AND
LEARN HOW TO BE A PRODUCTIVE
EMPLOYEE. AND SHE HAS TAKEN THE
SKILLS SHE LEARNED FROM THERE,
AND SHE'S TAKEN HER TO VET
SCHOOL, AND SHE'S DOING WELL
BECAUSE OF IT. BUT THIS YOUNG
MAN HE WOUND UP BUYING THAT
RITA'S FRANCHISE. AND WHEN I
TALKED TO HIM JUST TWO MONTHS
AGO HE TOLD ME THAT WHEN THEY
INCORPORATE THIS IN APRIL HE
PROBABLY IS NOT GOING TO MAKE
IT. AND HE'S NOT JUST GOING TO
SHUT HIS BUSINESS DOWN AND
CREATE ANOTHER VACANCY IN ONE OF
OUR SHOPPING CENTERS. HE'S GOING
TO GO SET UP BUSINESS SOMEWHERE
ELSE. WHERE HE CAN MAKE A
LIVING. WHERE HE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL. WHY ARE WE NOT
INCLUDING BUSINESSES LIKE THAT?
IN THIS AND I'LL TELL YOU, WHY
NOT? BECAUSE HE CANNOT DONATE TO
A CAMPAIGN. THE ABSOLUTELY CAN'T
HE'S HE'S ON A RAZOR THIN MARGIN
AS IT IS AND NOW WE'RE PUSHING
THEM OUT. WE'RE PUSHING THEM
OUT. OR DENYING JOBS TO OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. MY DAUGHTER WAS
NOT IN A UNION. SHE'S NOT GOING
TO BE IN A UNION. FOR THE FAST
FOOD INDUSTRY. WE DON'T NEED A
COUNCIL TELLING THESE FOLKS HOW
TO RUN THEIR BUSINESSES. WE NEED
US TO GET OUT OF THEIR BUSINESS.
LET THEM BE SUCCESSFUL. LET OUR
KIDS HAVE JOBS. FOR PETE'S SAKE,
STOP MAKING EXEMPTIONS. JUST FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS AND THE ABILITY TO
PAY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
AND THAT STINKS. THAT'S BAD
LEGISLATION. WE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF OURSELVES FOR PASSING
STUFF LIKE THIS. THANK YOU.
SENATOR èC R TO ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEN NINE SENATOR
LIMÓN. YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THE BILL BEFORE US
TODAY HAS BEEN THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TWO
SEPARATE COMMITTEES HERE IN THE
SENATE AND RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. THIS BILL IS CLARIFYING
IN NATURE AND SIMPLY ENSURES
THAT RESTAURANTS OPERATED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH LARGE
FACILITIES WILL NOT BE SUBJECT
TO THE PROVISIONS OF A B 1228.
THE BILL AND THE LANGUAGE BEFORE
US IS NOT REFLECTIVE OF WHAT
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION HAVE
RAISED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I VOTE. I'LL BE HAVING èC
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE RULE
REMINDER OF MEMBERS IS THAT TWO
THIRDS VOTE. IT'S AN URGENCY,
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HØI IG. AYE, ARCHULETA. AY,
ASHBY IY ATKINS PECKER. AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. AYE, BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE, DALLY.
NÓ TODD. AYE, DURAZO. AYE, EGM.
AYE GLASER. AYE, AYE. GONZALEZ
ALL GROVE. HURTADO. HØI JONES.
LAIRD. HØI AYE, MCGUIRE. ALL
RIGHT, MENJIVAR. AYE, MEN. AY
NEWMAN I WHEN NÓ NILO. OR CHILD.
BUT THE PORTANTINO. THE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. AYE, RUBIO.
AYO. NÓ SKINNER. AYE. HØI STERN.
I HUMBERG AYE. WELL, HÌ.
ALRIGHTY WIENER. AYE, WILK. THIS
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
GROVE. JONES. OR èC. WELL. A
VOTE OF 31 TO 4 ON THE URGENCY
31 TO 4 ON THE MEASURE. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE BACK TO
OUR REGULAR AGENDA PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. SENATOR GROVE ON
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. GREAT
ANITA. SEE NÓ MICROPHONES UP.
WE'LL CONTINUE ON WITH MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
WILL BE DEEMED RED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE. WILL BE DEEMED READ
IN AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WILL BE
NEXT TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. THERE ARE NONE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO EXCUSE ME.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
FIRST UP GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO ARE VERY ALERT
SENATOR SENATOR GROVE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO. SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU. MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS. THERE
ARE QUITE A FEW DOCTOR NICK BOYD
AND WENDY STRACK FOR THE BOARD
OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES. AND UM
NORINA LIONE FOR HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY AND BRIGADIER GENERAL
SYLVIA CROCKETT. I'M JUST GONNA
READ THAT NAME ONE MORE TIME
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S UH PRETTY
AMAZING THAT WE HAVE A ONE STAR
GENERAL. UM. BEING APPOINTED
BRIGADIER GENERAL SYLVIA
CROCKETT, BRANDON SHEPHERD AND
VERONICA, UH, ZIE FOR THE
VETERANS BOARD ALEX RODRIGUEZ
FOR THE CENTER, COAST REGIONAL
WATER BOARD AND ALEXANDRA HART
FOR THE NORTH COAST REGIONAL
WATER BOARD. THESE APPOINTMENTS
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY 21 ON A 50
VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE
. ANY DISCUSSION ON THESE
NOMINEES ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
THE NON SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. TALENT. HØI ALDO G.
AYE. ARCHULETA, IY ASHBY. AYE,
ATKINS. BECKER. AYE, BLAKESPEAR.
AYE, BRADFORD. AYE, CABALLERO.
ALL CORTESI. AYE, DALLY. DOD.
AYE, DURAZO. HØI EDMUND. AYE
GLASER. AY, AY GONZALEZ AY GROVE
AY. UH, JONES. AYE, LAIRD. A
LEMON. UH, MCGUIRE. AYE,
MENJIVAR. ALL RIGHT, MAN. UH,
NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN HIY NILO. AYE
Ó. AY PAD ALL RIGHT,
PORTANTINO. AYE, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO. AYE,
SKINNER. AYE, SMALL CUEVAS. AYE,
STERN. HØI HUMBERG. AYE. WHAT
AYE, WEINER. AYE, WILK. HØI. ON
A VOTE OF 38 TO 0. THE NOMINEES
ARE CONFIRMED. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT MEMBERS TO, UH, SENATE
THIRD READING. WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS. ON THE SCHEDULE TODAY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER. 713 AND 14
WILL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 106
BY SENATOR PADILLA RELATIVE TO
GM ONE GANG AOSIS WEDNESDAY.
SENATOR PADILLA AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR PADILLA
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NUMBER 106
, WHICH DECLARES MAY 23RD 2024
AS GM ONE GANGLIOSIDOSIS DAY. GM
ONE. GANGLIOSIDOSIS IS A RARE
INHERITED GENETIC DISORDER THAT
PRIMARILY AFFECTS CHILDREN. OF
THOSE IMPACTED OVER HALF PASS
AWAY BEFORE THEIR FIFTH
BIRTHDAY. GM ONE HAS MANY
DEVASTATING SYMPTOMS, INCLUDING
DEVELOPMENTAL REGRESSION,
MOBILITY, DETERIORATION,
SEIZURES, VISUAL IMPAIRMENT AND
NEURODEGENERATION. GM ONE IS A
PROGRESSIVE DISORDER AND THUS
EARLY DIAGNOSIS IS A CRUCIAL
FACTOR IN MANAGING SYMPTOMS WITH
MEDICATIONS, THERAPY AND
PALLIATIVE CARE. QUICKER
DIAGNOSIS IS VITAL TO LIMITING
THE DAMAGE THAT GM ONE CAN
INFLICT. BUT THERE ARE STILL NÓ
APPROVED TREATMENTS FOR THIS
DISEASE. UNFORTUNATELY AS RARE
DISEASES SO OFTEN DO GM ONE
PATIENTS SUFFER FROM A LACK OF
AWARENESS OF THEIR CONDITION. JM
ONE OFTEN GOES SEVERELY UNDER
DIAGNOSED OR MISDIAGNOSED,
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DIFFICULTY
IN ACCESSING SERVICES AND
TREATMENTS. TODAY FEBRUARY 29TH
IS A RARE DISEASE DAY. IT'S THE
MOST APPROPRIATE THAT WE BRING
ATTENTION TO A DISEASE THAT HAS
TAKEN SO MANY YOUNG LIVES, THE
GREATER AWARENESS THAT CAN BE
RAISED FOR THIS DISEASE. THE
BETTER CHANCE WE HAVE TO FIND A
CURE AND HELP BETTER THE LIVES
OF ALL OF THOSE THAT ARE
IMPACTED. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
ON S¼ èC R 106. THANK YOU,
SENATOR PADILLA ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEE NÓ OBJECTION. I IS. 38
NÓ ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND
RECOGNIZE SENATOR PADILLA AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU AGAIN, MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I HAVE
THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU DR DAVID LAW.
AND DR VENUS SISSON, THE PARENTS
OF VIOLET LAW. WHO PASSED AWAY
FROM GM ONE IN NOVEMBER OF LAST
YEAR. THEIR WORK. WITH èC GM.
ONE FOUNDATION HAS HELPED MANY
FAMILIES LIKE THEIRS FIGHT THIS
DISEASE. JOINING DAVID AND VINA
ARE MORE OF VIOLET'S FAMILY WHO
HAVE COME HERE TODAY TO
CELEBRATE HER YOUNG LIFE AND
HELP BRING AWARENESS TO THE
FIGHT AGAINST GM ONE I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE IN
ABSENTIA CHRISTINE WAGNER, WHO
WAS UNABLE TO JOIN US TODAY, BUT
HAS BEEN PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER
OF THE èC GM ONE FOUNDATION AND
HAS DEDICATED HER LIFE. TO
ERADICATING GM ONE. MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES. LET'S
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM SENATE
WELCOME.
AFTER SENATOR PADILLA HAS HIS
PHOTOGRAPH TAKEN. MEMBERS ARE
ALSO WELCOME TO JOIN.
WE'LL DO ONE MORE PICTURE WITH
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO JOIN.
OK, WE'RE ALL SET. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NÓ ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, CONTINUING UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. WE WANT
TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR ALVARADO
GILL FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION. SENATOR ALVARADO
GILL, PLEASE GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE. I AM HERE
STAFF. STAFFING OUR FUTURE.
SENATOR UH, RICHIE. RAYMOND
REYES. UM, HE IS A MEMBER OF
GENERATION ALPHA. AND MUCH OF
THE WORK THAT WE DO IS GOING TO
IMPACT OUR GENERATION ALPHA. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING HIM
HERE TODAY IS MY FIRST GRANDSON
AND AS YOU CAN SEE, HE'S VERY
SPIRITED. WELCOME TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE MORE
IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE
MEMBERS TODAY. THIS IS AN
INTERESTING DAY TO HAVE A
BIRTHDAY. BUT TODAY IS SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR. IT'S BIRTHDAY. LET'S
GIVE HER OUR CONGRATULATIONS.
WE'VE ALWAYS SAID SENATOR BLAKE,
THREE YEAR YOUNGER THAN YOU LOOK
SO UH, THAT WAS THE WRONG WAY. I
SAID THAT BACKWARDS. MY
APOLOGIES. ALL RIGHT. OK, PUT IT
IN YOUR EVALUATION. PUT IT IN
YOUR EVALUATION. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE NEXT TO SENATE. THIRD
READING HAVE AN ESCAPE THIS
MOMENT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO
SENATE THIRD READING. MEMBERS.
NEXT UP IS FIVE ITEM 13. THIS IS
A SENATE. BILL 66 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. HE'S PREPARED,
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION 66 BY SENATOR NEWMAN
RELATIVE TO 211 INFORMATION AND
REFERRAL SERVICE. SENATOR NEWMAN
. UH, THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE EXACTLY AS OLD AS YOU
LOOK. UH I RISE TO PRESENT S¼ R
66, WHICH PROCLAIMS FEBRUARY
2024 AS TWO ON ONE MONTH IN THE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, UH,
EVERY DAY, COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS GRAPPLE WITH
CHALLENGES IN SECURING SHELTER
SEEKING AID AND ACCESSING
ESSENTIAL SERVICES. CALIFORNIA'S
211 SYSTEM OFFERS THEM AN
ESSENTIAL POINT OF ENTRY AND A
BEACON OF HOPE, SERVING AS AN
INVALUABLE RESOURCE FOR
NAVIGATING COMPLEX SYSTEMS TO
ACCESS ESSENTIAL AID AND
RESOURCES ACROSS THE NATION.
50,000 PEOPLE USE Q. EACH DAY TO
CONNECT WITH AGENCIES TO AID
WITH UTILITY BILLS, TREAT MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE,
PROVIDE FOOD AND CLOTHES AND
DELIVER DISASTER RELIEF. THE 211
SYSTEM CAN BE LIKENED TO 911 BUT
FOR SOCIAL SERVICES SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN 2006, CALIFORNIA'S
211 NETWORK HAS FILLED IN MORE
THAN 20 MILLION INDIVIDUAL
REQUESTS, WHILE ASSUMING AN
INDISPENSABLE ROLE IN OUR
STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SOCIAL SERVICE DELIVERY NETWORKS
, THE STATEWIDE 211 SYSTEMS
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
NONPROFITS ENSURE THAT
ASSISTANCE IS AVAILABLE AND
TAILORED. EACH UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE AND LOCATION IN 22
ALONE, THE 211 SYSTEM
FACILITATED MORE THAN 2 MILLION
CONNECTIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
ADDRESSING CRITICAL NEEDS LIKE
HOUSING, INSECURITY, HUNGER
RELIEF, HEALTHCARE, ACCESS,
UTILITY ASSISTANCE, FINANCIAL
COACHING AND PANDEMIC. RESPONSE
FOR THOSE WHO NEED 211 HAS
BECOME A LIFELINE, UH, WITH
AROUND THE CLOCK ACCESS TO
HIGHLY TRAINED STAFF FLUENT IN
OVER 200 LANGUAGES, AS WELL AS
ACCESS VIA TEXT AND THE INTERNET
. I'M VERY HONORED TO INTRODUCE
S¼ R 66, WHICH FEBRUARY. 1120 24
AS 201 DAY IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
MONTH OF FEBRUARY AS TWO ON ONE
MONTH TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
CELEBRATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
201 TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND TO
OUR STATE IN RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ESSENTIAL ROLE
OF TWO ON ONE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO COMMEND THE UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA, WHICH PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL FINANCIAL AND
ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORT TO 211
AND ITS PARTNERS. UP AND DOWN
OUR STATE. I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SALUTING THE WORK OF
TWO ON ONE WITH AN I VOTE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NEWMAN. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
RESOLUTION ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEE NÓ
OBJECTIONS. I 38 NÓ ZEROS. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM.
14 THIS IS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 113. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 113 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS RELATIVE TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. SENATOR SMALL
CUEVAS. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. AND
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 113. THIS
RESOLUTION CHALLENGES ALL OF US
TO RECOGNIZE AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE
APPALLING HISTORY OF SLAVERY IN
CALIFORNIA. MY HOPE IS THAT IT
WILL CHALLENGE US ALL TO BEGIN
THE HEALING PROCESS BY OPENLY
DISCUSSING THE TRUTH, WHICH WE
CAN LEAD WHICH WE KNOW WILL LEAD
TO RECONCILIATION, ATONEMENT AND
GREATER UNITY IN THIS GREAT
STATE. THIS RESOLUTION IS ROOTED
IN THE RECENT EFFORTS OF THE
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE, WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED IN 2020 TO
CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE REPORT OF
ALL THE IMPACTS OF SLAVERY IN
THE EFFECTS ON BLACK AMERICAN.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
THE TASK FORCE DEDICATED
THEMSELVES OVER TWO YEARS TO
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF RESEARCH,
ACADEMIC HEARINGS AND COMMUNITY
INPUT FROM ACROSS THE STATE
REPRESENTING SO MANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. IN SHORT, THIS
EXHAUSTIVE REPORT DETAILS WHAT
BLACK PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
IN THIS STATE KNOW ALL TOO WELL.
THE VIOLENCE AND THE HARMS OF
SLAVERY DID NOT END IN 1865. IT
SIMPLY MUTATED INTO MORE DEADLY
POLICIES AND BLATANTLY
RESTRICTIVE ACTIONS THAT
PURPOSELY TRUNCATED ALL ASPECTS
OF THE BLACK COMMUNITY'S ABILITY
TO DEVELOP TO GROW TO CONTRIBUTE
TO PROSPER TO BE FULL, FULLY
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS. THE TASK
FORCE USES THE GUIDELINES SET BY
THE UNITED NATIONS AS THEIR
STANDARD FOR ADDRESSING
REPARATIONS UNDER ITS
INTERNATIONAL HUMANITARIAN ACT,
AND THE FIRST STEP IS
ACKNOWLEDGMENT. AND THAT'S WHAT
TODAY'S RESOLUTION IS ABOUT
THESE HARMS AGAINST BLACK PEOPLE
DATE BACK TO 1619 WHEN AFRICANS
WERE BRUTALLY BROUGHT TO AMERICA
AGAINST THEIR WILL, UNLIKE NÓ
OTHER HUMAN EXPERIENCE IN
AMERICA, MILLIONS OF BLACK
PEOPLE WERE RIPPED FROM THEIR
HOMELANDS. 5000 MILES AWAY,
AUCTIONED OFF LIKE CATTLE AND
TERRORIZING BONDAGE AND FORCED
TO ENDURE GENOCIDAL LABOR UNDER
THE MOST HUMANE CONDITIONS,
AMASSING UPWARDS OF ESTIMATIONS
OF $20 TRILLION IN ON THE BACKS
OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE, WOMEN, MEN
AND CHILDREN, MAKING THE U S¼,
THE LARGEST ECONOMIC POWER IN
THE WORLD, BUT ALSO CREATING OUR
NATION'S OLDEST WAGE THEFT CLAIM
THAT HAS YET TO BE PAID.
CALIFORNIA FURTHER PERPETUATED
THE HARMS OF BLACK AMERICANS BY
ENFORCING RACIST LAWS AND
DISCRIMINATORY DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES. I SHOULD SAY
EMANATING FROM THE STATES ORIGIN
WHILE CALIFORNIA ENTERED THE
UNION IN 1850 AS A FREE STATE,
IT DID NOT ENACT LAWS TO
GUARANTEE FREEDOM FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST ELECTED
GOVERNOR IN 1849, PETER
HARDIMAN, BURNETT WAS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST. AND HE ENCOURAGED
LAWS THAT EXCLUDED BLACK PEOPLE
FROM LIVING IN THE STATE. AND IN
FACT THEY CALLED HIM WHIP LASH
BURNET. BECAUSE IF YOU DIDN'T
LEAVE THE STATE THEY WOULD WHIP
YOU UNTIL YOU AS A BLACK PERSON.
THEY WOULD WHIP YOU UNTIL YOU
WERE OUT OF THE BORDER ACROSS
THE BORDER. IN 1852, THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
ENFORCED THE FEDERAL FUGITIVE
SLAVE ACT, WHICH ALLOWED FOR THE
CAPTURE AND THE RETURN. OF ANY
RUNAWAY SLAVE FOUND IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
PROHIBITED THINGS LIKE
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE,
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE. AND THE
RIGHT TO OWN PROPERTY IN THE
STATE. THE HARMS TO BLACK PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO
REVERBERATE IN THE 20TH CENTURY
BARRING VOTING FOR BLACK.
RESIDENTS. AND ENACTING POLL
TAXES AND LITERATE LITERACY
TESTS, SO THIS WAS NOT IN
ALABAMA. POLL TESTS WERE RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
DISENFRANCHISING BLACK
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA
PROPAGATED DISCRIMINATORY
HOUSING POLICY THROUGH REDLINING
BEGINNING IN THE 19 THIRTIES,
WHEN THE STATE ENABLED COMPANIES
TO RED LINE COMMUNITIES
PREVENTING BLACK PEOPLE FROM
SECURING HOME LOANS, MUCH LESS
TURNING, UH, OBTAINING HOME
OWNERSHIP AND LATER, UH, IN IN
THE 20TH CENTURY, WHEN BLACK
FOLKS WERE ABLE TO, UH, OBTAIN
HOME LOANS. UM, THERE, UH, HOMES
WERE DEEPLY DEVALUED WITHIN THE
RED LINE. WE ENACTED RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS. WE BARRED LICENSING
LAWS FOR PROFESSIONALS. WE UH
DID NOT, UH, ENFORCE FIRE AND
SAFETY CODES AND ANTI NUISANCE
LAWS TO PROTECT BLACK BUSINESSES
. THE CHAINS OF BONDAGE TOOK ON
MANY FORMS, AND THE LIST IS LONG
AND I HOPE, UH, YOU ALL RECEIVED
A COPY OF THIS 100 PAGE. UH TASK
FORCE REPORT THAT OUTLINES IN
DETAIL EVERY SINGLE ATROCITY
THAT WAS COMMITTED BY THE STATE
AGAINST BLACK. PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FROM THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO QUALITY, HEALTH CARE
AND EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES TO
INVOLUNTARY SCIENTIFIC
EXPERIMENTATION TO THE
ASSASSINATION OF BLACK LEADERS.
AND LYNCHING. IN HERE IN IN
CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW THE RUTHLESS
PRACTICES FAR TOO WELL. AND WE
KNOW THERE ARE TOO MANY TO LIST
AND WE KNOW THE PRICE IS TOO
GREAT. AND WHILE WE'D LIKE TO
THINK THAT ENSLAVEMENT OF BLACK
AMERICANS AND ITS ENSUING
IMPACTS ARE RELICS OF THE PAST,
WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE LOOK
UNDERNEATH EVERY CRISIS IN THIS
STATE TODAY, WE'RE GONNA FIND A
SLAVE ERA. AND WE'VE GOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ADDRESS THESE THESE
TRAUMAS. THESE TRAUMAS THAT RUN
DEEP IN THE FINANCIAL IN THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL HEALTH OF BLACK
CALIFORNIANS. THE TRUTH OF
HISTORY IS INDISPUTABLE. AND
ACCORDINGLY, WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THE ROLE OF THE STATE. OUR
GOVERNMENT, OUR OFFICIALS AND
PERPETUATING THESE HARMS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS RESOLUTION DOES
. TODAY IT'S A CHANCE FOR US TO
SAY WE KNOW AND WE RECOGNIZE.
THIS RESOLUTION IS JUST THE
FIRST STEP. IN ACKNOWLEDGMENT.
AND WE KNOW THE NEXT STEPS WILL
BE ACTION. AND SO TODAY WE ARE
ACKNOWLEDGING THE FACTS. WE ARE
NOT SUBSCRIBING TO FAKE
SCHOLARSHIP AND FAKE NEWS. WE
ARE UNDERSTANDING THE. DEEP AND
GENERATIONAL EFFECTS OF HARM.
THAT WE SEE EVERY DAY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS A RESULT OF THIS
HORRIFIC HORRIFIC PRACTICE OF
SLAVERY. THIS RESOLUTION IS
ABOUT HEALING. IT'S A FOUNDATION
FOR ALL OF US TO MOVE FORWARD
AND TO BUILD THE REAL WEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THIS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
RESOLUTION? SENATOR NELA. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. IT IS.
CERTAINLY TRUE. THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS. HAVE SUFFERED.
SIGNIFICANT DISCRIMINATION AND
DISADVANTAGES. IN CALIFORNIA AND
EXCUSE ME IN THE UNITED STATES.
I CERTAINLY CAN'T OPPOSE THAT.
BUT I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
RESOLUTION. FIRST OF ALL, I
THINK UH, BY TAKING OFFICIAL
ACTION OF THE ROLE OF THE STATE.
IN THESE ISSUES. I THINK WE OPEN
OURSELVES UP TO, UH, ALLEGATIONS
FROM A CLEVER ENOUGH ATTORNEY
FOR A CIVIL RIGHTS SUIT. BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHAT CONCERNS
ME IS WHAT IS NOT SAID IN THIS
RESOLUTION. AND THAT IS. OUR Kò
THROUGH 12 EDUCATION SYSTEM.
BLACK STUDENTS. AND THE Kò
THROUGH 12 SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE THE LOWEST FORMING ETHNIC
RACIAL COHORT. IN THE STATE. I
SHOULD SAY THE LOWEST ACHIEVING
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS. NOW. THIS IS NOT
BECAUSE OF NATIVE AVA, UH,
NATIVE ABILITY. IT IS BECAUSE
OUR CASE THROUGH 12 SYSTEM IN
THIS STATE FAILS. OUR MINORITY
STUDENTS. ESPECIALLY BLACK
STUDENTS. AND THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM FROM THAT, FROM MY
STANDPOINT FROM MY OPINION. IS
THAT. IF WE COULD ERASE ALL OF
THE ILLS ALL OF THE WAREHOUSES
IN THIS RESOLUTION BLACK. YOUTH.
WOULD STILL BE DISADVANTAGED. AS
ADULT SUCCESS. BECAUSE OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM FAILS THEM. WE
CANNOT FULLY OVERCOME THIS UNTIL
WE FIX THAT. IT IS, IN MY
OPINION, ALMOST SCANDALOUS. AND
I HAVE COMMITTED TO DISCUSS WHAT
IT IS THAT WE CAN DO ABOUT THIS.
BUT I THINK THAT IS AN
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL PART OF
WHAT THIS RESOLUTION IS
ATTEMPTING TO GET AT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS RESOLUTION, SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS, I
RISE. AND SUPPORT OF THIS COMMON
SENSE. UH UH S¼ èC R 113. TO
ACKNOWLEDGE A STATE AT THE HARMS
AND ATROCITIES COMMITTED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AGAINST
ENSLAVED PEOPLE AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS. OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS, I HAD TO DISTINCT HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE. TO DEDICATE A
GREAT PORTION OF MY LIFE ON
SERVING ON THIS CALIFORNIA
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE, THE
FIRST IN THE NATION. WE ST WE
HEARD TESTIMONY, WE GATHERED
EVIDENCE AND ULTIMATELY
DOCUMENTED THE HARMS CAUSED BY
BOTH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
1100 PAGE. FINAL REPORT
IDENTIFIED THE HARMS TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND THEIR DESCENDANTS,
WHICH INCLUDE DEVASTATING HEALTH
DISPARITIES DISPROPORTIONATE
OVER POLICING AND MASS
INCARCERATION, THE
DISCRIMINATORY HOUSING PRACTICES
, UH, UNEQUAL EDUCATION AS
STATED IN THE RACIALLY MOTIVATED
UNJUST TAKING OF PROPERTY. AND
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA ENTERED THE
UNION AS A FREE STATE, THEY WERE
A FREE STATE IN NAME ONLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT STILL TOOK PART
IN THE INJUSTICES JUST LIKE ANY
SOUTHERN STATE DID. INJUSTICES
WHICH INCLUDED THE PASSAGE AS
STATED AS A FUGITIVE SLAVE LAW
TO RETURN SLAVES TO THEIR
MASTERS. THE USE OF EMINENT
DOMAIN TO DISPLACE COMMUNITIES
AND CONFISCATE PROPERTY. THIS
CREATED NEGATIVE DISPARITIES IN
WEALTH. AND QUALITY OF NON WHITE
NEIGHBORHOODS. MANY PEOPLE ARE
NOT AWARE THAT CALIFORNIA DIDN'T
EVEN RATIFY THE 14TH AND 15TH
AMENDMENTS THAT WAS PASSED IN
1868 AND 1870 UNTIL 1959 AND
1962. ALMOST 90 YEARS TO RATIFY
THOSE TWO CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT PROMISED EQUAL
RIGHTS FOR ALL CITIZENS AND
PROHIBITED STATES FROM DENYING A
PERSON'S RIGHT TO VOTE ON THE
BASIS OF RACE. IF CALIFORNIA
HOPES TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND REPAIR
THE DAMAGE AND BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF HEALING. WE MUST TAKE ACTION
TODAY. ONE OF THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE TASK
FORCE. IS THIS OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION RECOGNITION OF THE
HARMS CAUSED THERE ARE STILL
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
STATE. WHO ARE EITHER NOT AWARE.
OF THE STATE'S REAL ROLE, OR
THEY JUST CHOOSE TO LOOK AWAY
AND LIVE IN A FANTASY WORLD. I
ENCOURAGE EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
YOU. TO READ THE 1100 PAGE
REPORT. IF NOT TO 1100 PAGE
REPORT, AT LEAST THE EXECUTIVE
SUMMARY. AND I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT OUR GOVERNOR HAS READ ALL
100 PAGES. BUT I ENCOURAGE, BUT
I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE FINDINGS
OF A RECENT STATEWIDE POLL THAT
SHOWS THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE THE HARMS
CAUSED BY SLAVERY CONTINUE TO
IMPACT BLACK RESIDENTS TODAY.
FOR ME. THAT IS A GOOD PLACE TO
START THE CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
STEPS WE SHOULD TAKE TO REPAIR
AND HEAR THE HEAL THESE ONGOING
HARMS EDUCATING ALL CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT THEIR ENDURING HARMS OF
SLAVERY AND OUR STATE AND A
RACIALLY DISCRIMINATORY POLICIES
THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED WILL BE
CRITICAL IF WE ARE EVER GOING TO
FULFILL THE PROMISE OF EQUAL
TREATMENT FOR ALL MR PRESIDENT,
COMMISSIONER REED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, I WOULD LIKE TO, UH,
RECITE A POEM BY NOTED EDUCATOR
POET AUTHOR DOCTOR J. JOHN
SIMPLY ENTITLED THE COTTON
FIELD. ROLLS AND ROLLS OF
NEGROES AND AFROS. IN CORNROWS,
ELBOWS, THE ELBOWS DRAGGING PICK
HOLES IN THE THS OF WHO KNOWS
BUT I SUPPOSE THEY KNOWS COTTON
ALWAYS GROWS AND THERE AIN'T NÓ
CHANCE OF WINTER SNOWS NÓ HER
HURRICANE BLOWS TO PAUSE THEIR
WOES OR THE BLOODY FOOTPRINTS
THEY SOLD, SO THEY JUST KEEP ON
SINGING. FROM HEAD TO TOES.
CARRY THEY BLOWS ON THEIR BACK
SCARRED LIKE TRACKS LIKE BROKEN
ARROWS, WISHING THEY WERE A
RAPPER, HOES OR SEMINOLES
ANYTHING BUT WHIPLASH NEGROES.
AND THERE, THERE AIN'T NÓ NÓ
SHOWS. THEY ALL KEEP STANDING AS
THE SUN BLAZES AND STEALS LIFE
FROM THEIR BONE MARROWS. THEIR
EYES NARROW. SWEAT FALLS FROM
BURNT SKIN LIKE NERVOUS SPARROWS
BECAUSE IF ONE FALLS THEY ALL
FALSE, LIKE ROWS AND ROWS OF
DOMINOES. ONE DOES FALL. BUT HE
QUICK THE ROSE HE ROSE. THEN
ANOTHER FAIL, BUT SHE QUIT THE
ROSE. SHE ROSE. SHE ROSE AND HE
ROSE ROWS AND ROWS OF NEGROES
AND AFROS AND CORNROWS ELBOWS TO
ELBOWS, DRAGGING PICK HOLES IN
THE THROES OF WHO KNOWS, BUT I
SUPPOSE THEY KNOWS. THEY KNOW
THEY LIVE FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S
BETTER TOMORROWS. THEY KNOW THAT
THEY THEY LAWS ARE FOR SO YOU
AND I CAN LIVE LIKE WE SUPPOSE
GOD BLESS THOSE BEAUTIFUL
NEGROES. MEMBERS. LET'S TAKE THE
FIRST STEP. LET'S RECOGNIZE THE
REAL HISTORY OF OUR STATE. LET'S
COME TOGETHER AND VOTE I ON S¼
èC R 113. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. NEXT UP, SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. UH I RISE
TODAY TO SPECIFICALLY REQUEST AN
I VOTE FOR S¼ èC R 113. I DO
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALL HAVE
TO DO AS POLICYMAKERS, BUT AS
HUMAN BEINGS IS ACKNOWLEDGED
WRONGS THAT WERE DONE. WHETHER
WE WERE A PART OF THEM OR
WHETHER WE AGREED WITH THEM OR
WHETHER IT HAPPENED AND WE HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THEM. UH, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LEARN FROM THE PAST
AND ALSO ENSURE THAT ALL OF US
ARE HEALING. AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT HOW DIVERSE CALIFORNIA IS,
UM OUR DIVERSITY IS ONLY
BENEFICIAL IF WE ALL ENSURE THAT
WE LOVE EACH OTHER, AND I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
ALL TRY TO DO HERE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS CREATE POLICIES
THAT BETTER IMPACT OTHER
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND 40 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS, AND THIS COMES
AGAIN WITH A STRONG HISTORY IN
DOING WHAT RIGHT, BUT WE CAN
ONLY DO WHAT'S RIGHT WHEN WE
ACTUALLY LEARN FROM THE PAST. UM
AND S¼ èC R 113 IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE WRONGS
DONE. UM FOR YEARS, RIGHT BY
THIS GREAT STATE, SO, UH, I
FULLY SUPPORT S¼ èC R 113. I
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FROM L A.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
CAN ALL DO BETTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. I HAVE
SENATOR D¯ÚI RAZZO, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR STERN, SENATOR DE RAZZO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ èC, R 113 AND MY
SISTER, UH, SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES. I KNOW THIS BILL WILL
PASS. WE HAVE THE VOTES HERE.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF BILLS
THAT COME THROUGH AND WE AS A
GROUP, WE DO IT, BUT I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE TO INDIVIDUALLY RAISE MY
VOICE. WHAT WE ARE ASKING THIS
RESOLUTION IS MERELY ASKING US
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARM
COMMITTED BY REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THINK
ABOUT IT. WHO PROMOTED WHO
FACILITATED WHO ENFORCED AND
PERMITTED THE INSTITUTION OF
SHADOW SLAVERY AND THE LEGACY OF
ONGOING BADGES AND INCIDENTS OF
SLAVERY THAT FORMED THE SYSTEMIC
STRUCTURES OF DISCRIMINATION
EXCEPT THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL OF THESE
HARMS AND ATROCITIES. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ASKED TO VOTE ON
TODAY, AND I IMAGINE THE
SLIGHTEST HESITATION. TO COME
FORWARD AND SPEAK UP AND ALSO TO
VOTE THE RIGHT WAY. THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR STERN. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. UH THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. UM I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION AND GIVING A
LITTLE. LITTLE BIT OF SIMILAR
PERSPECTIVE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FROM HAYWARD. UM. SUFFERING IS
HALVED WHEN IT'S SHARED. THERE'S
A THERE'S A SENSE OF ATOMIZATION
. I THINK IN OUR OUR POLITICS
RIGHT NOW THAT EACH PERSON
SHOULD BE IN THEIR OWN SILO, AND
THAT BLACK AMERICANS SHOULD
SHOULD HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE OF REPARATIONS AND OF
SLAVERY. AND THAT JEWISH
AMERICANS SHOULD HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THEIR ISSUE AND MUSLIM
AMERICAN AND THAT EVERYONE SORT
OF ON THEIR OWN TO DEAL WITH
THEIR OWN. CARRIED LEGACIES. UH
THAT'S NOT HOW THIS COUNTRY
WORKS. THAT'S NOT HOW WE'RE
BUILT. THERE'S A COMPLICITY THAT
WE ALL SHARE IN BENEFITING FROM
THE INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT ON THE BACKS OF SLAVERY
AND OF SLAVES. UM. THE I HAVE A
PROUD, I SUPPOSE. WITH THE. THE
ASSERTION THAT THIS IS AN
EXPOSURE TO CIVIL RIGHTS,
LITIGATION OR PART OF ME WISHES
IT WAS, BY THE WAY. ARMY THINKS
THERE NEEDS TO BE, UM BUT BUT IT
CLEARLY SAYS IN THE ANALYSIS
HERE THAT THIS IS NOT A GETTING
INTO THE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY ISSUE. UH OR EVEN
THE, UH UH, LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY
PER S¼ E. IT'S A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY. THAT'S IT'S IN
THE ANALYSIS OF THE BILL. UM
IT'S IN THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL. THAT'S THE HARD PART
HERE IS IF WE CAN'T GET TO THE
POINT OF JUST A BASIC MORAL
ACKNOWLEDGMENT. AND WE'RE GOING
TO GET TO THE APOLOGY. NEXT WITH
THE ASSEMBLY BILL COMING OUR WAY
. IF WE CAN'T EVEN GET THERE,
IT'S REALLY HARD TO KNOW WHERE
WE CAN GO. SO I HOPE AS A BODY,
WE CAN AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE
FACTS AND START THERE AND MAYBE
THROUGH THAT THERE'S A
RECONCILIATION PROCESS. BUT WE
ARE CER. CERTAINLY, STILL, UH,
WE HAVE WOUNDS THAT HAVE HAVE
NOT EVEN HEALED. THERE AREN'T
EVEN SCARS YET BECAUSE IT IS
STILL BEING PERPETUATED, AND
THERE'S STILL INEQUITIES
EMBEDDED IN THE SYSTEM THAT
MAKES THIS SYSTEMICALLY
ECONOMICALLY AND MORALLY UNEQUAL
. UM LET'S AT LEAST DEAL WITH
THE MORAL PART. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR STERN ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS RESOLUTION
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? NÓ
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. YOU
MAY CLOSE THE DEBATE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MR PRESIDENT. I WANT TO
REALLY THANK MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ACROSS THE STATE FOR STANDING
WITH ME ON THIS ACKNOWLEDGMENT.
UM, I GREW UP WITH MY MAMA. MY
GREAT GREAT GRANDMOTHER, UH,
WHEN I WENT HOME TO NORTH
CAROLINA IN THE SUMMERS AND
STAYED WITH MY GREAT AND GREAT
AUNTS, HER MOTHER WAS A SLAVE.
AND THIS WOMAN TAUGHT ME HOW TO
BLOW A KISS. WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT HOW FAR REMOVED AND YOU
KNOW WHEN THIS HAPPENED. THIS IS
IN OUR LIVES NOW. SHE TOLD ME
HER PAIN. IN THE EXPERIENCES
THAT HER MOTHER WENT THROUGH.
AND MY MOTHER. SHE TOLD MY HER
MY GRANDMOTHER AND MY MOTHER
TOLD ME SO. WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
A PAIN THAT IS SO RAW. AND AN
ECONOMIC, PSYCHOLOGICAL HEALTH.
REVERBERATION THAT IS FELT SO
DEEPLY. THAT IF WE COULD JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
BLACK PEOPLE, WE WOULD KNOW
WHETHER IT'S HOMELESSNESS.
WHETHER IT'S INFANT MORTALITY.
THAT IF WE CAN JUST ADDRESS THE
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE EXISTED
FROM THE LEGACY OF THIS HORRIBLE
ECONOMIC SYSTEM. THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THE CRISES THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A
PROBLEM BUT NOT A CRISIS. BUT
BECAUSE BLACK PEOPLE ARE SO
OVERREPRESENTED. SO
OVERREPRESENTED. THIS LEGACY OF
SLAVERY. WE ARE FIGHTING EVERY
SINGLE DAY BECAUSE BLACK PEOPLE
ARE SO OVERREPRESENTED IN THESE
CONDITIONS, AND IT STARTS. IT
STARTS WITH STORIES AND FAMILIES
LIKE MINE. MY MAMA. SO I JUST
WANNA SAY WE HAVE WORK TO DO.
AND YES, THIS IS NOT BINDING.
THIS IS NOT BINDING, BUT THOSE
BILLS WILL COME AND AS A BODY.
WE HAVE TO STRAIGHTEN OUR BACKS
AND DO THE WORK OF JUSTICE. IT
WILL FREE US IT WILL FREE
CALIFORNIA. AND WE WILL HAVE A
NEW DAY. WHEN WE SAID WE
ACKNOWLEDGE WE ACTED IN THE DAYS
OF IGNORING. AND
MISCHARACTERIZING FACTS. ARE
OVER. GIVING US A NEW BEGINNING.
SO I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. I'LL DEBATE HAVING èC
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE, ALDO G. HØI ARCHULETA,
HØI ASHBY, IY ATKINS. BECKER.
AYE, BLAKESPEAR. HØI BRADFORD.
UH, CABALLERO. CORTESI. AYE,
DALLY. DODD. HØI DUO. ALL RIGHT,
EGM ALL GLAZER ALL GONZALEZ. ALL
CROW. HURTADO. ALL RIGHT, JONES.
LAIRD. HØI LEMON. ALRIGHTY.
MCGUIRE. ALRIGHTY, MENJIVAR. ALL
RIGHT, MAN. I NEWMAN AYE. WHEN
NÓ NILO. OR BUT AYE, PORTANTINO.
AYE, ROTH. AYE, RUBIO. IY SOAR
TO SKINNER. AYE. A SMALL VÀ. I
TURN. I HUMBERG IY WAHAB. HØI.
AYE WEINER. I WILL. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
DELHI. GROVE. JONES. NILO. B¢O
TOTO! WELL. AND A VOTE OF 31 TO
1. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO NEXT
MOVE TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
FOLLOWED BY, UH TURNING TO
OCEANS AND RESOLUTIONS FOR A
JOURNEY IN MEMORIES, BUT
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE FOUR
OF THEM BUD BUDGET SUB CHAIR
ANNOUNCEMENTS WILL BEGIN WITH
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR PRESIDENT. BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE ONE ON EDUCATION
WILL MEET IN ROOM 2100 IN THE
SWING SPACE UPON ADJOURNMENT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD,
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. UH, BUDGETS, TOO,
WILL BEGIN. 15 MINUTES AFTER
SESSION ADJOURNS IN ROOM 1200 IN
THE SWING SPACE SENATOR LÀ.
THANK YOU. BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE,
NUMBER FIVE ON CORRECTIONS,
PUBLIC SAFETY, JUDICIARY, LABOR
AND TRANSPORTATION WILL MEET 15
MINUTES UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION IN ROOM 112. SENATOR
MANJAR AT SENATOR CORTESE'S DESK
. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE. NUMBER THREE
WILL MEET IN 10 MINUTES IN ROOM
2200. 1010 MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT. OK SO NOTED. ALL
RIGHT, MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
NEXT TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO ADDRESS
ADJOURNED MEMORIES. FROM
SENATORS. I WANT TO FIRST, UH
RECOGNIZE SENATOR PADILLA.
PLEASE GIVE THEM YOUR ATTENTION
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF VIOLENT LAW. WHO
PASSED AWAY IN NOVEMBER OF THIS
PAST YEAR. THE AGE OF FOUR. SHE
WAS BORN WITH A RARE
NEUROLOGICAL CONDITION I
DESCRIBED EARLIER GM ONE
GANGLIOSIDOSIS. DURING HER LIFE.
YOUNG VIOLET ENJOYED SWIMMING
MUSIC TRIPS TO DISNEYLAND FOR
SURE. AND SPENDING TIME WITH HER
AMAZING AND LOVING FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. AND HER SHORT BATTLE
WITH GM. I SHE ALSO WAS A
PARTICIPANT. IN A CLINICAL
TRIAL. THAT BROUGHT VALUE AND
UNDERSTANDING. AND WILL HELP
PATIENTS WITH GM IN THEIR FIGHT
AGAINST THIS HORRIFIC DISEASE.
YOU MET EARLIER, HER PARENTS,
DAVID AND VINA AND THE REST OF
HER FAMILY BY INTRODUCED ON THE
FLOOR AND STILL REMAIN WITH US
IN THE GALLERY. WHO CHERISHED
HER EVERY SINGLE DAY OF HER
LIFE. AND FOUND WAYS IN THE
MIDST OF SOME OF THE MOST UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT ANY PARENT
WHATEVER HAVE NIGHTMARES ABOUT.
TOUCH HER WITH LOVE. AFTER HER
PASSING. DAVID AND LENA DECIDED
TO USE THEIR EXPERIENCES TO HELP
PARENTS AND FAMILIES IMPACTED BY
GM ONE. THROUGH THEIR ADVOCACY.
THEY ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
VIOLENCE, LEGACY AND INCREASE
AWARENESS FOR GM ONE PATIENTS
AROUND THE WORLD. HER YOUNG LIFE
WAS SHORT. DURING THAT TIME SHE
TOUCHED SO MANY OTHERS AND HER
IMPACT WILL CONTINUE. TO BE FELT
THROUGH THE WORK OF Kò GM ONE
FOUNDATION WITH HER FATHER, WHO
WAS A BOARD MEMBER. PLEASE JOIN
ME TODAY IN HONORING VIOLET BY
ADJOURNING IN HER PRECIOUS
MEMORY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PADILLA. PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL. NEXT. WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR ALLEN. MEMBERS
UH, IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT
I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN. IN THE MEMORY OF A TRUE
EXEMPLAR OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
MAYOR BILL BRAND, WHO PASSED
AWAY EARLIER THIS MONTH. BILL
WAS BEST KNOWN AS THE OUTSPOKEN
MAYOR OF REDONDO BEACH. A
VIBRANT COASTAL CITY IN MY
DISTRICT. THAT WAS EVERYTHING TO
BILL. THROUGHOUT HIS TWO TERMS
ON THE CITY COUNCIL, AND IN
SUBSEQUENT TWO TERMS AS MAYOR,
BILL STOOD, IS A DOGGED CHAMPION
FOR THE PRESERVATION AND
RESTORATION OF THE SOUTH BAYS,
COASTAL LANDS. AND DESPITE BEING
BORN IN DALLAS, TEXAS, AN EIGHT
YEAR OLD BILL WAS METAPHORICALLY
BAPTIZED IN THE WATERS OF
REDONDO SEASIDE LAGOON. AS A
PERMANENT CITIZEN OF THE SOUTH
BAY COMMUNITY, AND FROM THAT DAY
ON, HE DEVOTED EVERY MOMENT TO
IMMERSING HIMSELF IN
CONDITIONALLY IN ALL THAT MAKES
THE REGION SPECIAL. IS IT AS IF
TO MAKE UP FOR THE THOSE FIRST
EIGHT YEARS AWAY FROM HIS HOME?
BILL SPENT HIS FORMATIVE YEARS
SWIMMING AND SURFING AND THE
WAVES OF THE PACIFIC AND WHILE
THEY DIDN'T NECESSARILY SMOOTH
OVER HIS EDGES THEY DID INSTILL
AN UNDERSTANDING OF HIS PLACE IN
THE LARGER ECOSYSTEM AND OVER
THE NEXT FOUR DECADES THROUGH
HIS EDUCATION AND ENGINEERING
CAREER WORKING IN AVIATION. HIS
SENSE OF WONDER AND REVERENCE
FOR THE WATER AND THE COAST.
NEVER FADED. OVER THE YEARS.
BILL'S DEVOTION TO THE WATERMAN
LIFESTYLE LED HIM TO EVERY MAJOR
U S¼ SURF DESTINATION TO SWIM
THREE MILES IN THE SEA OF CORTEZ
TO TRAVEL TO THE FAR REACHES OF
THE GLOBE IN SEARCH OF A
MEMORABLE SWELL. AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL 2001 WITH THE PLAN FOR THE
HEART OF THE CITY DEVELOPMENT
IMPACTING THE REDONDO WATERFRONT
THAT HIS LOVE WAS CATALYZED INTO
, UH, THE TENACIOUS FIGHTING
SPIRIT THAT WOULD COME TO
CHARACTERIZE THE BILL BRAND
BRAND. AFTER THE PLANE SAILED
THROUGH BOTH THE PLANNING
COMMISSION AND THE CITY COUNCIL.
THE ENSUING BATTLE ALCHEMY BILL
THE WATERMAN TO BILL, THE
ACTIVIST AND ADVOCATE. THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT HE FORMED
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THAT YEAR
WOULD LIKE MINDED ACTIVISTS SUCH
AS JIM LIGHT AT THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION AND THEN COUNCIL
MEMBER CHRIS CAGLE WOULD
PERMANENTLY CHANGE HIS LIFE'S
TRAJECTORY. BILLS A NEWFOUND
ZEAL FOR CONSERVATION DIDN'T
SUCCEED DIDN'T SUBSIDE AND AFTER
THE PROJECT WAS QUASHED. INSTEAD
IT SENT HIM LOOKING FOR MORE
WAYS TO SUPPORT AND ENGAGE HIS
COMMUNITY AND TO DEFEND HIS
HOMETOWN AND HOME WATERS. IN
2004 BILL FOUNDED THE SOUTH BAY
PARKLAND CONSERVANCY TO SERVE AS
THE VOICE FOR LOCAL LAND
PRESERVATION ACROSS ALL FRA FROM
LOCAL TO FEDERAL THE A E S¼
POWER PLANT, THE COASTAL SITE OF
THE ORIGINAL HEART OF THE CITY
PROJECT EVENTUALLY BECAME THE
TARGET OF BILL'S FOCUS. BUILT ON
A HISTORIC TRIBAL SALTWATER
WETLANDS. THE POWER PLANT WAS A
TREMENDOUS EYESORE, A BEHEMOTH
PROVIDING VERY LITTLE POWER.
THERE WAS AN UNSIGHTLY POLLUTING
HOLDOVER FROM A DIFFERENT TIME.
BILL FINALLY. DECIDED TO BRING
HIS FIGHT TO THE DAAS LIKE SO
MANY OF US RUNNING FOR OFFICE IN
2009, WINNING A PIVOTAL SEAT ON
THE CITY COUNCIL, NOW UPON
HEARING THAT HER BROTHER WAS
GOING TO BE SERVING ON THE CITY
COUNCIL, HIS SISTER, SALLY SAID,
REALLY, BILL, THE GUY WHO
WOULDN'T SHOW UP FOR DINNER
BECAUSE THE WAVES WERE GOOD IS
GONNA HELP RUN THE CITY. WHAT
QUICKLY BECAME CLEAR WAS THAT
BILLS UNCONDITIONAL LOVE FOR
SURFING. LOVE THAT WAS WORTH
SKIPPING DINNER OVER. WAS THE
SAME. FEROCIOUS LOVE THAT HE
FELT FOR THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
AND THAT LOVE WAS HIS SUSTAINING
FORCE IN POLITICS THROUGHOUT HIS
YEARS OF REDONDO LEADERSHIP,
BILLS, ACTIVISM AND HEART FOR
HIS COMMUNITY WAS OFFERED TO ANY
AND ALL WHO NEEDED IT ALWAYS
FULLY AND FREELY. IT WAS HIS
WILLINGNESS TO FIGHT BATTLES
THAT HE KNEW HE WOULDN'T COME TO
FRUITION UNTIL THE NEXT
GENERATION THAT REALLY EMPOWERED
HIM TO AFFECT SUCH POWERFUL
CHANGE. IN HIS OWN LIFETIME. AND
DURING HIS TENURE, HE FOUGHT
TIRELESSLY TO SECURE STATE
FUNDING TO RESTORE THE SAME
SEASIDE LAGOON THAT CHANGED HIS
LIFE AS AN EIGHT YEAR OLD TO
KEEP IT OPEN YEAR ROUND FOR
FOLKS FROM ALL OVER L A TO ENJOY
WE KNOW THAT IT'S A PLACE WHERE
KIDS OFTEN TIMES FROM ALL OVER
LOS ANGELES, I GET TO EXPERIENCE
THE BEACH AND THE MÀ THE MAGIC
OF THE WATER FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME. HE BROUGHT THE WONDERFUL
BEACH LIFE MUSIC FESTIVALS TO
REDONDO BEACH, BOOSTING THE
LOCAL ECONOMY, SHARING THE
BEAUTY OF THE SOUTH BAY WITH
VISITORS. AS WAS HIS STYLE. HE
WANTED TO TAKE A PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO ADDRESS AND SUPPORT
THE LOCAL HOMELESS POPULATION,
INCLUDING THE INSTALLMENT OF
TINY HOMES FOR TEMPORARY HOUSING
, BRINGING IN HOMELESS COURTS
AND OTHER INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS.
AND PERHAPS MOST MEANINGFULLY,
MEANINGFULLY BILL WAS ABLE TO
OVERSEE THE DECOMMISSIONING OF
THE A E S¼ POWER PLANT, WHICH IS
THE CULMINATION OF DECADES OF
ACTIVISM IN A MAJOR STEP TOWARDS
THE RESTORATION OF THE LAND ON
WHICH IT'S WHICH IT SITS. THE
GOAL OF TAKING THE PLANT OFFLINE
, WHICH JUST SEEMED IMPOSSIBLE
20 YEARS AGO HAS BEEN ACHIEVED
AND CED A NEW GENERATION OF
ACTIVISM AT THE SITE, ALL DUE TO
BILLS, UNWILLINGNESS TO GIVE UP.
NEW YEAR'S EVE. DECEMBER 31ST
2023 WAS THE LAST TIME I SAW
BILL WE ALL GATHER TO MARK THE
DECOMMISSIONING OF THE PLANT THE
NEXT DAY NEW YEAR'S DAY. THIS
YEAR, 2024 AND THERE WAS THIS
WONDERFUL OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT,
AND I'M I'M SO GLAD BILL WAS
ABLE TO BE THERE. LOTS OF PEOPLE
TELLING THE STORY OF THE
DECOMMISSIONING OF THE PLANT. SO
MANY OF THE ACCOLADES FOCUSED ON
HIM AND HIS ROLE AND HIS
LEADERSHIP. SO JUSTIFIABLY I WAS
ABLE TO STAND UP THERE AND SPEAK
OF OUR DECADE OF WORK AND
PARTNERSHIP. FROM THE VERY FIRST
TIME WE GOT TOGETHER FOR DINNER
AT CAPTAIN KIDD'S ON THE HARBOR
WHEN I WAS FIRST RUNNING FOR
OFFICE THROUGH ALL THE WORK
COMING UP HERE TO THE SENATE,
WORKING ON FUNDING FOR THE
SEASIDE LAGOON, THE A E S¼
PLANT. OF MATTERS OF IMPORT TO
THE REDONDO COMMUNITY. BILL WAS
RELENTLESS. HE WAS DOGGED, HE
WAS DETERMINED. SO DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO HIS CITY AND ITS
PEOPLE. YOU KNOW, UH, MANY OF
YOU KNOW, MY I LOST MY FATHER
LAST YEAR IN IN THE YEARS
BUILDING UP TO HIS PASSING. WE
ALL KNEW HE WAS SICK, BUT HE
WOULD ALWAYS COME BACK AND HE'D
BE BETTER AGAIN. AND THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED WITH BILL. YOU KNOW, WE
I FOUND OUT SEVERAL YEARS AGO
THAT HE HAD CANCER. UH AND HE
WOULD GO OFFLINE FOR A LITTLE
BIT. GET SOME TREATMENT, BUT
THEN HE'D BE BACK. HE'D BE BACK
IN AN EVENT BACK CALLING ME
ASKING FOR SOMETHING BACK
ADVOCATING. AND I JUST THOUGHT
THAT THIS WAS THE NEW NORMAL
THAT WOULD GO ON FOREVER. BUT OF
COURSE CANCER CATCHES UP WITH
EVERYBODY. AND BILL ULTIMATELY
LEFT US WAY TOO SOON AT THE AGE
OF 66. AT PEACE AND COMFORTED BY
HIS WIFE, DEIRDRE FAMILY AND
CLOSE FRIENDS AFTER A VALIANT
4.5 YEAR BATTLE AGAINST CANCER.
UP UNTIL HIS FINAL DAY. HIS
FIRST AND LAST QUESTION WAS
ALWAYS WHAT CAN I DO? THE
SELFLESS COMMITMENT TO HIS
COMMUNITY WILL WILL NOT BE
FORGOTTEN THROUGH THROUGH ALL
THE LIFE AND LANDS THAT OWE
THEIR PRESERVATION TO HIM.
BILL'S HEART WILL REMAIN
INDELIBLY INEXTRICABLY WOVEN
INTO THE SOUTH BAY FOR
GENERATIONS. AND I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME TODAY. COLLEAGUES IN
COMMEMORATING BILL BRAND'S
LIFETIME OF PASSIONATE ADVOCACY
AND PUBLIC SERVICE. BY
ADJOURNING THE SENTENCE HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ALLEN. OUR CONDOLENCES
TO BILL BRANT'S FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD TO THE SENATE DESK SO HE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN
THE SENATE JOURNAL. IF THERE'S
NÓ OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE SENATOR MAGUIRE, THE DESK
IS CLEAR. MISTER PRESIDENT.
REALLY NICE JOB TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND TO THE MEMBERS OF
THIS ESTEEM BODY. HOPE YOU HAVE
A WONDERFUL WEEKEND WITH YOUR
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. THE NEXT
FOUR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY. MARCH 4TH 2024 AT 2 P.M.
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 330, AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT 2 P.M.